سوداني للجزيره ان الجيش السوداني علق
مشاركته في مفاوضات جده وكانت الوساطه
الامريكيه السعوديه اعلنت التوصل لاكثر من
اتفاق هدنه بين طرفي الصراع في السودان
بناء على مفاوضات اجريت في مدينه جده
بالسعوديه
ماذا ينقال مراسل الجزيره ان الشبكات
الواسعه نطاق دارت امس في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع واضاف مراسلنا للشبكات دارت
بين جانبين في شارع الغابه ومدخل جسر
الفتيحات بالعاصمه وشهدت اطلاق نار بانواع
مختلفه من الاسلحه وقالت غرفه الطوارئ بحي
الحلفايه الشماليه الخرطوم بحري ان ثلاثه
قتلى من السكان قتلوا جراء اعتداءات
نفذتها عناصر تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
على الحي وافادت مصادر سودانيه الجزيره
بوقوع الشباكات وسط شماليه الخرطوم اطلاق
نار كثيف جنوب شرقي مدينه الاوبيض بولايه
شمال كردفان
من جنوب الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
طاهر المرضي وابدا معك بالشقه السياسي
وتعليق المفاوضات ما المعلومات المتوفره
طبعا المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان ان هذا
المصدر الدبلوماسي وايضا هنالك مصدر عسكري
اكد ان الجيش السوداني علق مشاركته في هذه
المفاوضات في جده وتقول هذه المصادر ان
هذا التعليق
احتجاجا على خرق قوات الدعم السريع للهدنه
وهجوم على مواقع للجيش السوداني وتتحدث عن
هجوم ايضا عن مواقع في داخل ووسط الخرطوم
كالكتيبه الاستراتيجيه هذا التعليق تطور
جديد ربما يعزز ويعقد الامور اكثر على
الارض سواء كانت ميدانيا او حتى من
الناحيه الانسانيه
وهذه التعليق يعني حتى الان من المبكر ان
نسمع الردود فعل بالنسبه سواء كان الدعم
السريع او حتى بالنسبه للجنه الميسره
والمراقبه ايضا لعمليه وقف اط النار في
السودان بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع هذه هذا التعليق او هذه الاتهامات
الجيش اتهامات الجيش السوداني لقوات الدعم
السريع ليست الاولى ولكن كانت هنالك عده
اتهامات لقوات الدعم السريع بانها تقوم
بخرق هذه الهدنه وتقوم بمهاجمه
القوات الجيش السوداني في مواقعه وكذلك
كانت هنالك اتهامات من قوات الدعم السريع
للجيش السوداني
بانتهاك
وخرق هذه الهدنه اذا السيمة الاساسيه لكل
هذه الهدن التي وقعت بين الطرفين كانت هي
الاتهامات المتبادله والقر هذا ما قررت
ايضا اللجنه المراقبه لوقف اطلاق النار
وقالت ان هنالك خروقات كثيره تحدث في هذا
الاطار كما ان هنالك ايضا بنود اخرى لم
تنفذ بعد هي
عنا المستشفيات واخلاق المواقع المدنيه من
المظاهر العسكريه واتاحه الفرصه لاصلاح
الخدمات بالنسبه للمواطنين واتاحه ايضا
الفرصه للمواطنين للتحرك بحريه بعيدا عن
الارتكازات وعمليات التفتيش المتكرره في
هذا الاطار حتى الان اللجنه الميسر مكونه
من الولايات المتحده وكذلك المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لم تعلق على هذا التعليق
كيف يمكن ان تتخذ من اجراءات كيف يمكن لها
ان تعمل على وقف هذه
الخروقات التي تؤدي الى تعقيد ربما ايضا
الى تصاعد العمليات العسكريه في مثل هذه
الظروف الحرجه اشكرك يا جزيل الشكر من
جنوب الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره طاهر المرت